the film american fighter you're the
co-writer sean is that right yes i
co-wrote it and directed it oh great
okay and it has martial arts elements to
it yep oh yeah yep there's martial arts
so definitely drew from some of that
experience and it's interesting because
it takes place in 1981 so it's kind of
pre-mma in that whole thing
so it deals with kind of illegal
underground fighting
so certainly martial arts involved but
there's also this kind of street
fighting brawling
thing that happens as well and and
and wrestling and so it integrates a lot
of different uh
fighting styles if we take a look at the
first page for the screenplay that you
co-wrote american fighter
our protagonist is raza and you see
kind of his life
it seems like it jumps back to different
parts can you talk about that yeah so
the main character actually ali he
the opening of the film which which i
felt was was important was to kind of
tell this story kind of jumping back and
forth and it opens with him
in kind of the fight of his life the
movie starts with this you see some
images some flashes and pieces of this
fight and where he's kind of going to be
at the lowest point as well
and then we take a step back and the
film is then going to lead up to that
moment again
and the reason for that was it wasn't
originally written that way this was a
you know the later and then to the
shooting draft we decided that it was
important to have
show that element right away number one
to kind of it's that big impactful start
like get audiences interested and
curious like wait a minute why is this
happening why are these two people
fighting and there's a huge crowd around
them and and uh
you know what is it all about we see our
hero fall right like right in this the
end of this beginning fight he gets
almost knocked unconscious and so we go
from there to him waking up in his
college dorm room and uh that's you know
several weeks earlier or months earlier
he's worried about his his family's
supposed to be flying because he's from
iran and he's worried about and this is
1981. so the setting is
the iraq iran war uh had just started
and it was a terrible time in that area
and just
like two years earlier was the iran
hostage crisis that happened and so in
america at that time
it was not a great time to be iranian
and so he had to face those kinds of
issues but so he wakes up this college
dorm room uh he's got a roommate who's a
good friend and but he's really afraid
for his parents he wants
them to make it over
from iran safely to the u.s and so
uh and his roommate's trying to assure
him that he's going to be fine and
they've got wrestling practice and so
the idea the concept is he is there for
like a wrestling scholarship
and that's part of what helped get him
out of iran
uh
iran i should say not iran but iran
helped get him out of iran
because of his wrestling prowess
and so
he's now trying to
help his parents get over
because his mom is sick she has cancer
and so he's trying to get her to
to some more western medicine
um and that's kind of what jumps off the
the story so in the first page if i
remember correctly there's is like a
sort of these different flashes so he's
getting beat up then
you see like a happy moment where he's
running and saying mom i'm coming to
america look at the letter or something
there's a flash of the picture of the
ayatollah
and then there's
the mother being hooked up to tubes so
all these like sort of things are coming
at you yeah that's when he gets uh
knocked unconscious
um he flashes back to his
childhood when he was back in iran
and uh he's kind of flashing to the
moment that he found out
uh that his mother
that something was wrong with his mom
so that's kind of uh that's what's
happening there um he's not running
excited that he's going to to america
what's happening is actually his father
is
telling him he's going to send him there
because he'll be safer oh okay sorry so
he's going to go live with his uncle
um
in america and he's actually
disappointed like he's he's scared about
this prospect of having to leave his
family
um but they you know recognize that he
has the opportunity there he's obviously
really good at wrestling and that can
that's what's creating this opportunity
for him to get out
um of the really bad situation that was
happening at that time
and so it's almost a nightmare of what
he's experiencing um
and that leads him into waking up in his
dorm room
um and so yes he hears a new news
broadcast you know he's he's that's
it's maybe a little bit different in the
actual film versus what's on the page
but basically there's news broadcasts
happening talking about the events that
are that are happening during that time
uh and that kind of
crosses with what his father is telling
him about i need to send you to america
and
and then him
rushing to see his mother
and i always had this like kind of
haunting image of following him kind of
in
you know a slower motion as he's making
his way down this hallway to this door
that's cracked open
and as he
as he pushes the door open he sees his
mother and she looks at him smiling
and as she tries to stand up
to talk to him she collapses and that's
the the terror he's he's uh
having in that moment it's actually
based on something that really happened
to me so that was that was a moment
directly ripped from my own childhood
and uh
my mother is still here so i'll preface
it that way but she
had an aneurysm
so it wasn't cancer but it was an
aneurysm and she collapsed in a very
similar way and it was that terrifying
you know
and i had my own kind of fevered
nightmares for years and years about it
um
and so that's a little piece of me that
made it into the the script there that's
melded with other kind of uh
memories from ali as well ali afshar
because he produced it and this
character is actually based on him now
this story has some real elements but
other ones are you know we fabricated
for for for the movie but um the
character himself is based on ali and
his because he's also a wrestler and all
of that stuff and he did come over from
iran
and uh
and all that have some similar
experiences there
so you really see the stakes are high so
it's not just he's being pulled from his
homeland leaving his family there's
government turmoil his mother is sick so
everything's kind of thrown in that
first page
all stakes are like you know what he's
dealing with yep right there okay yep
okay did page one did it evolve did it
change was it definitely did
yeah it definitely evolved and at first
we didn't see that fight happening uh
and uh
right away um it did always kind of
start with that dream
so that was there uh from the beginning
but yeah it evolved there was many many
different drafts of it and we we
experimented with different ways to open
it um and ultimately that's what we
settled on um was kind of yeah throwing
all the all the and i there is a kind of
a funny story to as to why
uh we ended up going that direction and
within the movie because the time it was
it was the summer
um
what was the school year after the
summer that uh
star wars empire strikes back came out
um and
so within the script that was all the
rage at the time like everybody was
talking about especially obviously the
first star wars was such a huge success
and then this follow up with yoda and
everything and the controversial
ending of empire strikes back sorry
spoilers but darth vader is luke's
father
um that's like all anybody talked about
at that time and so we worked that into
the script i'm a huge star wars
nerd myself i love star wars and so
a lot of that
my personality was coming out through
the script in that way too so we have
ali's roommates characters really into
star wars and he can't believe that ali
has never seen star wars so that is a
running joke through the whole script
and he's doing yoda impressions very
terribly by the way but um doing them
nonetheless and and uh so i thought that
was a really fun thing to to help
set the tone and time
place that this movie was set
um
but the other thing that i thought about
was
looking at great movies like that like
the original star wars how does it open
it opens with such a bang i mean it's
just right off the bat
action is happening spaceships are
flying overhead lasers are going you
know you just get
all this all the stakes are set right
there and so that influenced how the
opening pages of our movie
um
happened it was like obviously we don't
have spaceships and all that fun stuff
but we want to
throw it in your face right away like
start it with a bang and hopefully get
the audience hooked right there right
from the first flash you see on screen
and like whoa what's happening oh my
gosh it's a fight you know and oh look
at this kick and this punch and oh he's
oh no he's he's down already you know is
is uh
directly kind of influenced from star
wars uh and like how the rebels
immediately their ship gets captured by
the bad guys and all hope looks lost
right away you know so um yeah
with american fighter are we
establishing i'm sorry is it reza is it
is he is he the main character or not
ali oh sorry for some reason i may have
sent you i may have sent you a draft
that had the wrong name like oh okay we
did play with it not being uh ali at one
point so that's probably the draft you
got no problem i was searching for those
drafts and i couldn't find because again
a different computer three years ago
so i think i must have sent you the
wrong one uh on accident in page one of
american fighter are we establishing
ali's kind of personality or we're just
more seeing the stakes that he's against
i think yeah it's more about the stakes
that he's against because in the first
page we don't get to see maybe a ton of
his personality um but that does come
out right kind of in this in the the
subsequent pages you get to know him a
little bit more um
and uh
and
comes out in some of the playful banter
with him and his roommate and
and uh but the the story does get very
serious very quick for ali so
unfortunately he doesn't get uh
uh a lot of lighthearted time uh in this
in this particular film
is this first page still the opening of
the movie
more or less yeah there were some tweaks
that that in some stylistic choices that
we played with but uh it's not exactly
but yeah there's a lot of it is still
there
so what was the log line for american
fighter did you or like if you were
going to do your elevator pitch what was
it sort of oh my gosh it's been so long
fight club meets wrestlers yeah it's
it's it's it's uh uh
it really is it's like
got equal parts rocky and and karate kid
i mean those are
those
it's got a lot of heart
um and and and blood sport i don't know
how many people know bloodsport but uh
it's it's kind of an amalgamation of all
those things um but again like i said
the the heart and the reason why he
fights is to try and save his mother so
that's kind of at the core of it um
uh
and that kind of sets it apart from
those movies in a way
um
but yeah it's the it's the journey for
this character ali like
uh
how far is he willing to go for for love
you know for family and it's a love
story about his there is a love interest
in it and played by the awesome alison
page she's amazing but the the core of
the love story is actually that for his
his mother you know and he's willing to
do anything to help save her
and including fighting in underground
bare-knuckle brawls putting his you know
life at risk
if it means he can
save her because the story is is
actually very tragic his father is
killed um
uh when they try and leave the country
and it has to deal with the with the the
uh
the
events that were going on at that time
so
how many drafts did you have of the
script oh my gosh lots
lots probably too many to count like
official drafts you know we go through
the different colors once we we started
pre-production
um
probably good six or seven or something
like that
um
that's like from initial like breaking
maybe more like five
um
but yeah all in
at least a dozen
yeah
at least probably more